okay so cobra kai is filled with a ton
of easter eggs hidden details and
references to the karate kid movies much
like season three the show is packed
with call backs and in this video we're
gonna be breaking them all down now the
series culminates with daniel and chosin
making an alliance at mr miyagi's grave
chosen was the villain in the karate kid
too and you might remember that daniel
actually ended up running into him
during the midpoint of season 3. he gave
him a secret scroll from mr miyagi's
collection and anthony could actually be
seen looking over this in episode 7. it
detailed a special pressure point punch
technique that daniel somewhat used
against johnny to paralyze his arm much
in the same way that his was now chosen
ended up actually honking on daniel's
nose which was actually a callback to
karate kid 2 when daniel did the same
thing after he beat him mr miyagi's
gravestone has popped up throughout the
seasons and much like we already saw it
details how he was a war hero that
received the medal of honor throughout
the season daniel very much adopted a
defense only mentality which somewhat
led to him and johnny parting ways
however this likely shows that he's
gonna now fully embrace all that to make
a more balanced combat style chosen
actually beat daniel in season 3 and
therefore he's probably the best person
that he could have teamed up with
interestingly this season also ends with
silva announcing that he's opening
several karbakai's throughout the valley
and this was actually his original
planning karate kit iii but he was
stopped by daniel now he started the
entry immediately after the events of
season 3 with a new dojo being formed in
the background we can also catch mr
miyagi's car which was something that
was a big part of the original movies it
also showed up at the beginning of
season 3 which is where we met a young
john crease in season 3 there was a
bully that was played by martin carvey's
son jesse but the big twist came when we
saw that the young john was actually a
victim the car appears throughout the
season and in real life the studio
actually gave it to ralph macchio once
filming had wrapped cars have become not
only a fascination for the actor but
also the character who is of course a
cast salesman now they of course do wax
on wax off and we can also catch ores
which are a reference to the balancing
belt that too has showed up throughout
several of the films and also the
seasons one of the students actually
vomits in this and yeah don't go sitting
down in that anyone make sure you
balance johnny and his students very
much end up doing the jobs that he did
in season one such as waxing and sanding
but this time it's for training whereas
that was to make ends meet this could
somewhat explain why he finds it
demeaning and decides to go off and
start his own dojo now johnny ends up
sweeping hawke's leg at one point which
is of course a signature move by kobakai
who often do this kind of thing as it's
an easy move to trip someone up with
clearly the two sides just don't get
along and later on in the episode miguel
goes to johnny and talks about rocky 3
which is when rocky and creed teamed up
this is of course paying lip service to
how johnny and daniel were enemies at
one point but have now joined together
now at one point in episode five johnny
also trains to the song burning hop by
survivor which comes from the rocky iv
soundtrack during this he runs on the
beach which is also likely a nod to when
apollo and rocky did it in the third
movie the scene also contains a deleted
one from the original film in which
daniel embarrasses johnny and i'm
actually surprised that they put this in
here with it being deleted i'm kind of
wondering if it was almost a repressed
memory coming up and it kind of helps to
push daniel and johnny further apart
there's also several references to
bloodsport laced throughout the series
and the kids later end up watching this
at the drive-in this actually has a
scene in it in which someone catches a
fish with his bare hands which is
something that the students later
attempt to do in episode 3. devon lee
also brings up the film when she joins
eagle fang and i like that they kept
referencing this film throughout the
season as it's a classic she also
mentioned cynthia rothrock an american
80s movie star that was in a lot of
martial arts films she also brings up
the best of the best and that's not a
men in black reference although i wish
it was it's actually a call back to a
taekwondo film from the 80s now we also
get mention of top gun in episode 4 when
johnny is in bed with carmen johnny sees
val kilmer's iceman as the hero of that
and this of course very much reflects
how he was the villain of the karate kid
but he sees himself as a good guy in
episode 8 after he's beaten up he
actually sings a song from the top gun
soundtrack called playing with the boys
by kenny loggin in episode 4 daniel also
brings up the band chicago whose singer
peter cetera sang the song glory of love
for the karate kid 2 soundtrack miguel
later brings up this song in the same
episode and yeah it's a banger i don't
care yet i love my 80s smush rock now
weirdly johnny says peter cetera isn't a
badass so yeah i hope the guy wasn't
watching this now when we cut to
karbakai we can see a cardboard cut out
of crease this is a reference to the
first film in which he also had one in
the dojo after getting ghosted by silva
he ends up showing up at his house where
he catches him having a party one of the
guests says that he has a habsburg jaw
which is a nod to the old german royal
family the habsburgs had a habit of
marrying their cousins and people
connected to their bloodline but it just
led to them getting massive protruding
jaws so it's not really a compliment
silva also calls daniel danny boy which
is what he called him in karate kid 3 as
a means of intimidation daniel makes a
peace offering with some cures and
johnny of course drinks seas all the
time however we learn in the season that
his dad actually all ceased to drink it
and that johnny kept one of his cans as
a reminder of his father in episode 2
johnny ends up drinking some of daniel's
blue belgian white and daniel ends up
chopping the top of this bottle which is
a reference to when mr miyagi did it in
the films johnny complains that the beer
is too fruity and not to his taste which
is actually a bit of a play on how
ignorant he is as blue belgian white is
actually produced by molson coors who of
course also make course now speaking of
alcohol terry silva ends up kicking a
bottle of wine to show that he's back
and this actually has a name cayman on
it which is a nod to robert mark cayman
caiman is an american screenwriter that
wrote the first three films and he also
owns a vineyard called cayman estate
wine this actually appears on the wine
box and like i've been telling you for
years it's all connected now jump to
episode 2 and we get daniel trying to
teach johnny about mr miyagi's ways he
imparts a lot of his teachings into him
and also talks about shin po who founded
over 2000 dojos teaching the techniques
shin po and miyagi were related and he
very much kept his teachings alive kurt
kurbakai and we can catch your poster
hanging out for the 51st door valley the
date on this says 2019 and i'm guessing
that this series is just gonna probably
skip over everything that's happened in
the last two years which is probably for
the best because let's be honest we
don't want reminders now increases
office we can also catch a picture for
the us army which of course calls back
to his past marrying their sumi kenny
whose father's also in the army and they
pretty much reboot the daniel and johnny
origin story with him being a newcomer
in the town that gets bullied this is
carried out by anthony lupuso aka daniel
sun's son and at one point he chases him
to the point that kenny has to jump over
a fence this actually reflects when
daniel almost did it in the original
movie but unlike daniel kenny gets away
kenny's game attack is also kenny the
jet 99 which is a nod to benny the jet a
pioneer of kickboxing in the us kenny's
surname is also pain which to me makes
his dad a major pain but that might be a
reach
now johnny takes daniel to a weber
industrial warehouse and weber was
actually the original surname for daniel
in the script however after casting
ralph macchio they decided to change it
to a russo to reflect that he's italian
johnny puts daniel through the kobrakai
paces which includes hitting baseballs
something that he also had miguel do in
season 1. he also makes the character do
bare knuckle push-ups which a student
was forced to do in the first film when
miyagi and daniel visited kurbakai john
pulled one of his students out of the
lineup and then punished them by forcing
them to go off and do these they end up
having to fight with some hockey players
and after daniel kicks the crap out of
them he stands around doing the prone
waiting and pacing move that mr miyagi
also did after beating people up kindly
shows how much mr miyagi influenced him
and it's a really nice touch now jump
over to episode three and we very much
see the difference between johnny and
daniel daniel eats with chopsticks
whereas johnny won't and they also break
out the old protective pads that mr
miyagi had on top of this we also get
several flashbacks of silva's time in
vietnam which riff upon the third season
here we witnessed the pair getting their
matching cobra kai tattoos which have
both become staples of the characters
interestingly though we learn that silva
got his removed and i wouldn't be
surprised if down the line that it
showed back up again after he got a new
one tattoos are of course supposed to be
permanent and silva getting his lasered
off is also symbolic of how he tried to
forget the bond that he made with crease
jammed at episode 4 and both chris and
silva bow to one another which is a
reference to what they did in karate kid
3 before fighting mr miyagi throughout
this entry we also get lip service to
the ice breaking scene which was also
heavily tied in with chosen in addition
to this daniel brings up how his mother
dated mr harris who was a teacher that
popped up in the first film mr harris
didn't know him at the time but i bet he
knows him now after banging his mother
silva also brings up his line if a man
can't stand he can't fight he said this
to robbie and cobra kai but originally
the villain also said it to daniel
perhaps foreshadowing how robbie could
end up switching sides at some point
johnny says you couldn't leave well
enough alone which is a nod to when he
also said it in the first film this
actually came after daniel had sucked
him in the bathroom which may have been
given an odd 2 in this entry when cobra
kai gets sucked with the sprinklers
johnny also says don't be a cream puff
which is likely a reference to increased
cultivate in the first film pivotal
soleil a bit below the belt and i won't
stand for it not in my dojo cut to
episode 5 and both chris and terry go to
johnny and daniel to ask them to tell
their students to leave cobra kai alone
this is something that miyagi did to
kobakai in the first film and it's sort
of like poetry they rhyme terry's toxic
waste scandal is also brought up too
which we heard about in the third film i
don't know what it was with 80s movies
but there was always something involving
toxic waste and it even helped to make
the ninja turtles now shortly after this
scene we also see the johnny twitter
account in which you can see that he's
still using phrases like hashbrown
instead of hashtag now speaking of
twitter you guys can follow me at
heavyspoilers and if you've enjoyed the
video so far we'd massively appreciate
the thumbs up we do breakdowns like this
all the time so also show no mercy on
that subscribe button you're some of a
[ __ ] much love hope you had a great new
year as well now in episode six daniel
goes to robbie to warn him about silva
and he actually talks about how he
regrets breaking someone's nose and
getting blood all over his [ __ ] the
character actually did this in karate
kid 3 when he lashed out after losing
his temper he also slags off silva and
oh my oh my god he's standing behind me
isn't he episode 6 also has joni and
miguel trying to recruit girls at a
football match which could be a nod to
the first film also it's football yet
not soccer and you can't do anything
about that as youtube have disabled
dislikes you can't disagree now episode
7 fleshes out more of the rivalry
between anthony and kenny and we also
get a subtle call back to the original
karate kid film his friend says looks
like everyone's doing something new
which johnny's friends said in karate
kid1 and then he later visits the dojo
and we see several newspaper clippings
chronicling his dad's journey in the
original films in episode a we're
introduced to more of daniel's family
including his cousin vanessa this is
quite a cool cameo as she's actually
julia macchio who is ralph's daughter
johnny is called to meet silver at
chris's old dojo which is where the pair
tried to gang up on mr miyagi however he
ended up winning unlike johnny who gets
the crap kicked out of him you also see
terry's license plate is quicksilver
which isn't a nod to the x-men it's
actually a reference to the technique
that he developed now slowly things
build up to the old valley how we get a
performance by carrie underwood who
sings the moment of truth from the
original soundtrack oh my ending explain
yeah i joke that i didn't know what the
song was and said i didn't know what the
hell she was singing it was a joke yeah
please stop commenting just please leave
me alone plea please i'm begging now
knowing them what you mean you're
showing no mercy now knowing their moves
cobra kai are also able to beat a lot of
miyagido and miguel gets a back injury
this lays him out for a bit which is
very similar to what happened to daniel
in the first film but miguel ends up
leaving or as daniel returned daniel
also says never put passion before
principal which is an odd to mr miyagi's
teachings calling back to bloodsport
references we also see robbie doing what
i'm calling a wind down kick which is
something that van damme did in the film
in a further call back to karate kid 3
eli and robbie end up in sudden death
over time which also happened at the end
of that movie tori catches him paying
off the referee and he also ends a frame
increase for the attack on stink ray
that pretty much ends the season but
shouts chris from 3c films for pointing
out that it's kobra kai but in real life
cobras can't do karate pretty much shows
why he's the worst youtuber of all time
when he's sending easter eggs like that
and dislike dislike dislike
anyway that's the video and i'm sure
that with 10 episodes that i missed some
in there so make sure you let me know
below in the comments if there's any
that you spotted we're running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of an mc boxer of your
choice on the 30th of january and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the series we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter at heavyspoilers if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of the
season which will be linked on screen
right now we talked about the ending
gave our predictions for the future and
yeah go ahead over there because it's
not like you're doing anything else
today is it yeah you're watching youtube
videos if not then thanks for sitting
through the video i've been poor i'll
see you next one you take care of
yourself peace